pourquoi avoir créé une légende origine
c'est aussi bien que moi que qu'il faut
des légendes à tous les gens qui sortent
un petit peu durant il faut le leur faut
des étiquettes ou leur faut des légendes
alors plutôt comme les fabriques je me
les suis fabriqué moi même deux mois
sans voir le jour
mais habitude de dire
entièrement allergique à l'air pur
têtu c'est comme ça c'était une de mes
phrases clés pour la com ça se plaisait
beaucoup à la presse a fait ils ne
cèdent un titre régine est allergique à
l'air pur en vérité j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup la campagne
jean vit le jour en voisine vit le jour
bien entendu puisque
pour pour la chance je travaille dans la
journée
et pas de problème la journée c'est la
des jours avec soleil et des jours sans
soleil
on friday night et prennent soin
pixon hormis en chine
hélas les êtres qui se réfugie dans la
nuit son temps possible des gens qui ne
sont pas sûrs d'eux c'est déjà la
première chose on devrait savoir sur les
octobre les gens qui sont angoissés
effectivement et peut-être que lui la
nuit les problèmes paraissent moins
difficile ce qui est faux parce que moi
j'ai appris avec la nuit que pour vivre
la nuit pour être faite très solide
[Musique]
il m'a laissé le six canettes et le
disclaimer
je crois que c'est une chanteuse des
rues
le choix d'une chanson c'est d'abord
qu'elles ne correspondent bien sûr et
qu'elle soit humaine et chaleureuse où
peut-être avec de l'humour en dépend les
chansons je décide de choisir
je crois qu'elles ont toutes un lien de
tendresse en tout cas
je suis là et je veille j'écoute
l'été je suis vilaine on avoir l'une
avoue centre est une science jeune femme
ou le
camp des flux des madrigaux je
pleurerais une autre fois
je me sens forte en goût et que les
diables l'accompagnent
et je vais moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais une petite fille qui tremblaient
qui avait peur j'en suis sorti mais en
fait est ce qu'on en sort voilà ce que
j'en sors vraiment je crois que je
pourrais jamais en sortir je crois que
j'aurai toujours malgré moi une une
trouille permanente je n'y peux rien et
je crois que je veux même pas lutter
contre ça parce que c'est peut-être pour
ça que je peux chanter c'était pour ça
que je suis ce que je suis et je crois
qu'il faut jamais renier ce qu on est
avec les bons et les mauvais côtés je
suis un personnage je veux l'être en
plus je suis discuter et dans le fond je
crois qu'il faut être discutées pour
être un personnage il sort toujours
quelque chose de la discussion au bout
de tout ça et bien il y aura la vérité
quoi
[Musique]